[Music]
hey guys it's quinn here as always if
you appreciate my content hit the like
button it's the only way the youtube
algorithm really can see my videos
computer
access dune data banks study room 12.
accessing doom data banks
computer scan book
[Music]
computer run comparative analysis
algorithm 494 running algorithm
organism entering study room 12. that is
quite the collection of books what are
you up to oh it's you organism9186
yes it is i your rarely seen but ever
present interdimensional companion
organism 9186 is that brian herbert's
new dune book you have there
oh yeah i decided i'd start covering
more of the brian herbert kevin j
anderson material as well as the frank
herbert books and the dude encyclopedia
i'm just reading through all the
material again so i can better
understand it and try and get a grasp on
why some of the changes that were made
were made changes impossible according
to my research the expanded dune books
were created based on notes left behind
by frank herbert himself well apparently
so but that doesn't change the fact that
certain things in the brian herbert
books just don't really line up with
what was written in the previous frank
herbert books i do not comprehend i
demand you explain this to me
immediately
well for instance the fact that there's
a weird late to the second god emperor
gola and don't even get me started on
well actually i think this would be
easier to explain if i just made a video
the original dune saga ends on a
cliffhanger after six books written by
frank herbert many years after the
release of frank herbert's final book
two additional books intended to finish
off the original doom storyline were
published by frank herbert's son brian
herbert and science fiction author kevin
j anderson these books were said to be
based on notes left behind by frank
herbert and were considered to be a part
of the official canon of the dune saga
in the book hunters of dune the seventh
book in the official dune canon goals of
several key characters throughout the
dune saga have been created
duncan was the only one who remembered
them the way they had been
paul atreides lady jessica though fear
howard johnny stilgar the kinds dr yui
and the baby lato ii
they were just children now innocent and
sweet an unorthodox group with
mismatched ages
right now in one of the bright chambers
paul and his oddly younger mother were
playing together happily arranging toy
soldiers and military equipment around a
mock castle at the end of the sixth book
in the dune saga chapter house dune
duncan idaho and shigana broog who
possessed the memories of the former
benny jesuit mother superior o'draid
escaped the world chapter house on a no
ship called the ithaca
they also had just managed to escape the
net of the beings who referred to
themselves as daniel and marty
according to the brian herbert and kevin
g anderson books after their escape
aboard the no ship they used the cells
that were in the possession of the
tlalaxu master skytel to produce these
golas these cells were also mentioned in
the book chapter house dune but there
was no mention in that book that they
also possessed lato the second cells
each master had carried this resource
a null entropy capsule preserving the
seed cells of a multitude
fellow masters of the central kell face
dancers technical specialists and others
he knew would be attractive to the women
of chaitan
and to the many weakling poinda
paula tradies and his beloved johnny
were there
oh what that had cost in searching
garments of the dead for random cells
the original duncan was there with other
atreides minions the mint thufer howitt
gurney halek the freeman naib stilgar
enough potential servants and slaves to
people at leylaxu universe
the god emperor later ii certainly would
have recognized the potential danger of
a goal of being produced from his own
cells
i doubt that lay laksu would have been
able to acquire them unless he
intentionally allowed them to
which doesn't seem to add up given what
we know about later ii from frank
herbert's dune books
this new late to the second came into
being more than fifteen hundred years
after the death of the original though
later the second may have never truly
died considering that he himself refers
to his final metamorphosis in the book
god emperor of dune as a likeness of
death in which he would essentially be
frozen in time as a pearl of awareness
lato in the original dune series had
tasked himself with leading humankind
and preparing them for the great
struggles to come
but narratively speaking his gola exists
for another reason
lato had used to play laksu to create
golas of duncan idaho over and over
again no one truly knew the reason why
this is why the benny jesuit itself had
an interest in duncan
they were attempting to discover the god
emperor's purpose for seeing to duncan's
constant reincarnations they knew lato
never did anything without reason
as duncan watched he recalled how many
times he had tried to assassinate the
god emperor himself
and how many times later the second had
brought him back as a gola
gazing at the one-year-old child duncan
thought if anyone could find a way to
live forever it would be him
brian herbert and kevin j anderson's
work suggest that laeto had in fact made
a grave mistake according to sand worms
of dune lato had not known that he would
in fact not be the final quizadorak that
there was another the final gola of
duncan idaho we see the threads of this
idea in chapter house doom but in my
opinion there is nothing to suggest that
the significance of dunkin idaho was
lost on later the 2nd as i said the
sisterhood recognized that there was
something important about duncan and
chose to study him because of the
attention that the god emperor gave him
if duncan idaho had the potential to
become a kind of quiz at tatarak then
there is frankly no way that late to the
second would not have foreseen it
essentially later the second would have
been conditioning duncan idaho for what
was to come for thousands of years
the beings known as daniel and marty who
first appear in the later frank herbert
books are revealed in brian herbert's
material to be the thinking machines
omnius and erasmus who had escaped the
butlerian jihad thousands of years ago
and had created a machine empire out
amongst the scattering
eventually they capture the inhabitants
of the no ship ithaca
the gola version of lato that appears in
brian herbert's books could communicate
with the worms even more intimately than
shianna
the worms kept in the ship desired
freedom shiana and lato end up releasing
the worms into the thinking machine
capital
the creatures by burrowing in and out of
the planet's surface caused much
destruction
eventually the thinking machines are
defeated much due to duncan idaho's
transcendent new abilities
and though the eons spent inside a warm
body had been constant agonizing pain
for the original late to the second the
gola decides that he would be happiest
joined with one of the creatures he
merges with the worm and this time
becomes a non-conscious version of what
he was before
a genetic merger of sand worm and human
though i like some of the ideas
presented in brian herbert's books i do
think there are a few thematic
inconsistencies when comparing them to
the original series as i said the worm
body had been a horrifying prison for
later ii the loss of his humanity was
depicted as terrible but necessary
lato's death at the end of god emperor
of dune was peace for him a release
after eons of agony
the gola version of lato joining with
the worm body to become a non-human
non-conscious version of what he was is
to me nothing more than a meaningless
suicide
would it have not been better for this
gola lato at least to live out his life
naturally to regain the humanity that
the original had lost long ago
honestly i don't mind these so-called
changes so much and who are you to tell
brian herbert what's right he's frank
herbert's son not you
i get what you're saying but also [ __ ]
you but yeah you are right organism9186
at the end of the day it is just my
opinion the lato the second gola itself
is an interesting enough concept and
though it is great that brian herbert
and kevin g anderson did do an official
ending to the dune saga i will never
stop being curious as to what frank
herbert would have done differently if
he had had the chance to tell the story
for himself alright thanks for watching
guys make sure you like and subscribe
for more quinn's ideas
all right organism i hope that explains
everything i've got to get going now
i only allotted so much time for
research i'll see you later organism9186
i'm gonna go to my meditation chamber
teleporting to meditation chamber three
once a fool always a fool
computer
show all information angola production
[Music]
[Music]
foreign